- Buy me some ice cream?
Well, you know I struggle with dairy.
- That's because you hold it in, Mom.
You just gotta let it rip.
Everybody farts.
- I don't.
- Why would you torture yourself?
Just eat some ice cream.
Live in your body.
Oh, I literally have no pores.
- Mom, check out your biscuit.
Who knew you were such a big booty Judy.
- CC.
(playful music)
CC Walker, you have a tattoo?
Oh, absolutely not, CC.
- No, no, you cannot wear that to school.
I will die.
- Do you think you're
wearing this to my work?
- You look like an American Girl Doll.
- Are those your father's gym shorts?
- Is this Nancy Pelosi?
- You have paint on your jacket!
- Yeah, you gotta bow down to
the patriarchy, don't ya, Mom?
Just dress for the male gaze.
- Oh, you and your ideals.
Well, let me tell you something.
Ideals don't pay the bills.
(burping)
Oh, CC, what did you eat?
- Sorry, I pounded a Gatorade
on the way over here.
♪ Let's do it ♪
- Okay.
♪ Ride it ♪
- No, no, Mom!
Mom!
- Ride my pony.
- We don't do that.
Thank you, guy.
- I can't believe I thought
we could pull this off.
- Yeah, what happened
to "Miss I Got This"?
- Well, you fell down the steps, Mom.
Oh, it's so bad.
I don't think I can hold it in.
- Oh, yes you can.
You wanna know why?
There are 40 years of
farts in that stomach.
You will not let them out
on the most important day of my career.
- I don't wanna let 'em out.
I don't wanna let 'em out.
- Just breathe.
- You don't really care about me
and about what actually makes me happy.
You just want me to be like you,
and think like you, and act like you.
It's not about the national team.
I just wanna get away from you.
♪ Just bust a move ♪
This is absolutely unacceptable.
- I can explain.
- You can explain?
- I'm having fun.
Can you not just be happy for your mother?
- Moms don't dance like this.
♪ Just bust a move ♪
- I'm having fun.
You have fun in my body.
- For the rest of the
time you are in this body,
you're grounded.
But I am here stuck in this
hag body and you're just out
while I have your stupid friends
and your psycho dog baby.
- Is me having fun the problem?
Because I thought the
problem was me being a robot.
(Jess scoffs)
I am Jess Walker.
Your criticism does not compute.
- I'm sorry, Mom.
- No, no, CC.
- I didn't understand
how hard your job is.
And everything you do for our family.
- No, no, CC.
I'm the one who's sorry.
You were right, honey.
Your way works for you.
And it doesn't have to be
my way to be a good way.
More than anything in this entire world,
I just want you to be okay.
- I will be okay
'cause I have the best mom in the world
and that's how she raised me.
(both sniffling)
(tender music)
- We're looking for two
things in our players.
Good soccer, good character.
I've seen your tapes.
I knew you're a great soccer player.
When I saw you give up a game winning goal
to help an injured opponents,
I knew you had both.
- Oh my gosh.
Can you just hold on for one second?
Hey, Mom?
- [Jess] It's a miracle.
- This is the rep from the national team.
He just offered me another chance.
But I'm saying no, right?
- Wait.
No.
- Right.
I'm so sorry.
- No, we're saying yes.
You have to say yes.
And look, if soccer is the thing you love,
I'll be at every game.
- Really?
- Try and stop me.
- Thank you!
(uplifting music)